ciao this is Rebecca Allen and we are
from Italy visiting this beautiful place
in America called Los Angeles where you
can find a lot of interesting food from
anywhere sometimes it's good sometimes
it's bad today American style pizza
which I'm afraid I'm pretty curious
about it there's another thing that you
call pepperoni pizza what is actually
selamat becomes a pizza yeah pepperoni
so like the obvious what else is like
the devil's pizza because it's with a
spicy salami this is New York's not
pizza okay
I didn't expect it to be this thinner
yeah higher maybe somewhere else so I
think it's giant really it's a slap in
the face what I need over 150 for gas
[Music]
good but without salt I expected it
super so gonna be fine but faster and I
know it's it's good I really expected it
to be so much so much and it's I don't
know mmm this is like okay there are
versions of this pizza but it's always
like the pizza you order at 4 a.m.
hmm on the computer don't even call just
recently and waiting for aids at all
[Music]
like that so you yeah yeah you can
actually find you can find it yeah when
you're in dark places of your soul it's
kind of made like everything you got I
bet this sugar inside oh yes I don't
guys it sucks when he's too afraid to
get killed when she comes back its own
no no I know that's and I'm sure that I
don't think we expected to whoever
actually because we Italians have she's
been opinion about italian-american
dishes but actually wasn't that bad I
don't know what people keep complaining
about it so yeah
[Music]
why are cutting it like okay okay now
we're gonna try the fish pizza the
deep-dish pizza and I'm afraid and I
kind of wish there's pineapple inside
okay guys this deep-dish pizza is
freaking me out
everything smells like it smells like
what are you gonna fix a wall and it
looks
I never even yeah I saw it but there's
anything inside mushrooms Jesus really
guys why do you do that why do you have
to you know make it bigger and
exaggerate that much it looks like a
cheese cake when you guys work on a
cheese cake I never smelled the knife
inside anymore
mm-hmm super difficult this is
definitely the weirdest thing we have
ever eaten
Cardinal Vegas mm-hm I like it but
better than the other one mmm I prefer
these like if I have to eat something
really american-style
I prefer the Chicago style this point
I'm gonna try this cross because I
didn't it it's like like a an apple pie
I got that one look
[Music]
that's just like in the first pizza I
made when I was a kid
I've gone with my own um she let me do
them you know the little pizza now that
I've like feeding this war
italian-american stuff for like probably
half an hour I'm kind of enjoying this
Chicago but actually most parmigiana is
either probably a mix of mixes showed a
mix of cheeses this is really Oracle so
happy that I didn't this pizza I will
totally live to cheese because the pizza
can stay with this 12 ingredients yeah
if you take it like you know the 15 I
could order this secretly yeah well
nobody sees me
or at least sharing a home alone drunk
on the couch one yeah well at least with
people you know that can feel the shame
with me no no I'm sorry but I enjoyed
this pizza I actually I really enjoyed
it so yeah I like that even if I live
longer than but in the end I will eat it
again please please please don't do it
your way
accept tips and suggestions from other
people ok minimize you for having us and
make us test this yeah I guess we are
the renewed evolved Italians now here
ciao ciao guys thank you very much but I
live
[Music]